hey guys it's march first I'm chastity
I'm nursing a GDC hangover from last
night but it's only Wednesday so there
are more events to go yay here's your
news
first up a price drop for oculus rift
plus touch controller I still can't
afford it so who wants to go halfsies
today oculus is implementing a pair of
price cuts that it hopes will encourage
more people to adopt its VR headset for
six hundred dollars you can now get both
a rift headset and the oculus touch
controller that's a two hundred dollar
price drop for the bundle which was
previously priced at eight hundred
dollars the headset itself drops to five
hundred dollars though it's unclear if
that option will be eventually phased
out in favor of the bundle if you
already own a rift touch will now be
sold for one hundred dollars down from
200 you'll also be able to pick up an
additional oculus sensor for $59 today's
move brings rift closer to the price of
PS VR and gets beneath the vibe seven
hundred dollar price for more insight on
the price drop check out our interview
with oculus VP of content jason rubin on
gamespot com next up more details on
Xbox game pass yesterday we told you
about Microsoft's announcement of their
Xbox game past subscription service
Microsoft marketing boss aaron greenberg
talked on twitter about the service
greenberg confirmed that xbox game past
will only have a month by month
subscription option available priced at
ten dollars additionally greenberg said
that xbox game past can be shared as
part of xbox one's home sharing policy
there are more than ten confirmed titles
already including halo 5 fable three and
Gears of War ultimate edition Xbox game
pass is theoretically a threat to
retailers like gamestop in that it
provides access to an ever updating
catalog of digital games that
subscribers never actually owned and
thus cannot trade in after Microsoft
announced their Xbox game pass yesterday
gamestop stock value tanked dropping by
eight percent now Microsoft has
confirmed that it is working with the
store to offer Xbox game pass to
shoppers presumably in the form of
prepaid subscription cards xbox game
pass is expected to launch for all Xbox
one owners this spring and finally the
Ghost Recon wildlands beta set a new
Ubisoft record Ubisoft held multiple
betas for Ghost Recon wildlands
including a closed beta and in open beta
and now the publisher has confirmed that
more than 6.8 million people took part
in them this sets a new record for the
biggest beta phase in the company's
history by comparison the divisions 1
beta had 6.4 million players
Ubisoft also confirmed some stats from
the wildlands beta including the fact
that people play for more than 2 billion
minutes and that more than sixty percent
of people played cooperatively everyone
who took part in a wild lands beta will
get the unidad conspiracy bonus which
comes with three exclusive missions that
take place in the madea luna region
these missions will be available
sometime after wild lands comes out on
march 7th you also need to purchase and
play wild lands by march 31st on the
same Ubisoft account as the beta to
claim the reward do you want to see more
breadth of the wild of course you do so
join us tomorrow for our live stream
with the switch as we play Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild really early 8
a.m. pacific time so come hang out and
i'll see you tomorrow